la voile et moraux de là bas c'est une
des dernières fois où je la vois
l'extérieur partira par là bas et puis
on laissera tout ça derrière nous donc
après ça va être enfermé dans la boîte
avec tout l'équipage j'ai hâte ce petit
mélange de
d'impatience et de l'appréhension ça
devrait bien se passer nous pour ferrat
ancien militaire dans l'armée de terre
engagé en opération extérieure au tchad
et au mali ce n'est pas vraiment un bleu
la différence c'est que demain il
embarque comme seuls responsables de la
santé de ses collègues pour devenir le
sorcier l'infirmier du mort dans un sous
marin
la dernière journée à terre touche à sa
fin demain le départ mais avant les
sous-mariniers se retrouve sur le quai
pour un barbecue c'est la tradition la
veille des départs enfin un report comme
ça on est tous ensemble malgré qu'on
soit tous ensemble en quelques heures à
l'intérieur c'est comme ça c'est la
dernière petite bouffée d'oxygène avant
de porter son
génial
tout l'équipage dînent ensemble sans
distinction de grade du simple matelot
au commandant du navire benjamin que
tout le monde ici appelle le pacha
ça fait partie et c'est le moment de
cohésion qui sous de l'équipage et qui
permettent de constituer une équipe et
pas juste des gens qui travaillent
ensemble et qu'ils livrent chacun leur
vie dans leur coin jour le barbecue je
vais pas dire qui m'aime me suive mais
si je pouvais pas être tout seul ce
serait bien quand même
[Musique]
anthony qui fait demain le grand saut
vers l'inconnu passe un dernier coup de
fil à sa famille
[Musique]
c'était mon épouse
voilà
demande comment a été la journée parce
que je suis parti ce matin assez tôt là
parce que c'était un peu une journée
marathon là ce matin
première gens d'avant départ donc j'ai
demandé qu'on s'était passé la journée
et puis comment s'était passé la journée
pour les enfants silva sujet j'ai des
enfants c'est important d'avoir toujours
un petit mot avant de partir de partir
pas fâché
rassure un peu avant le départ parce que
forcément elle s'inquiète toujours un
petit peu c'est un peu comme toutes les
missions c'est toujours plus dur pour
celui qui reste à la maison et chacun a
ses petites astuces pour rendre la
séparation moins difficile pour ses
proches
à ma fille à papa il est parti mais
donne vraiment les dates et les jours et
puis elle est content elle a un
patron de ce club a qu'un petit serpent
et l koch les jours et elle sait qu'en
blanc on va rentrer
question vie de famille tous les sous
mariniers le sable et s'y préparent le
métier demande souvent des sacrifices
femme et mes enfants qui sont pas très
loin d'ici là quelque part vers le mont
faron voilà et
dernier petit coucou parce qu'il doit
battre avec les préparatifs je n'aurai
pas le temps de les voir moi c'est assez
simple parce que ils ont entre 5 et 12
ans dont ils se rendent compte et ça
fait quelques années que je dis sous
marin maintenant donc ils ont déjà déjà
visité ce soir-là
donnerait qui n'est quand j'étais en mer
je suis arrivé deux mois et demi après
le vrai faux que j'ai vu c'était sur le
quai oui c'est un peu dire effectivement
ça fait partie du métier
[Musique]